you have a system you wanted to do x you
give it a
set of examples and you say you know do
that do this kind of thing what could go
wrong
um well there's this laundry list of
things that could go wrong
what does the quote premature
optimization
is the root of all evil mean
so this line comes from donald knuth who
is one of the
uh i think of him as kind of like the
yoda
of computer science um just dispensing
these uh
these gems of wisdom um
and there are many i think many
like many aphorisms you can take it in a
number of different directions
one of the ways that i think about it is
um
you know a lot of a lot of the way that
we make progress in math and computer
science is through
models you make a model that sort of
approximates the
um the phenomenon that you're trying to
deal with
you know there's a great quote from
peter norvig another
uh one of these uh luminaries in
computer science
he's quoting someone from nasa saying
our job was not to land on mars it was
to land on the mathematical model of
mars
provided to us by the geologists um and
so this idea that premature optimization
is the root of all evil
um i think if you if you kind of mistake
the
map for the territory so to speak if you
forget that there's a gap
between your model and what the reality
actually is
then you can commit yourself
to a set of assumptions that are later
going to
bite you um and so this is the sort of
thing that people who are worried about
ai safety uh
you know this is what keeps them up at
night what is the alignment problem
that's what we're going to be talking
about today we might as well define our
terms
yeah so the alignment problem um is this
idea
in ai and machine learning of
the potential gap between what
your intention is when you build an ai
system or a machine learning system
the objective that the system has um so
it's the potential misalignment so to
speak
between uh your intention your
expectation
how you want the system to behave and
what that system
ultimately ends up doing why does it
matter
i mean this is this is a fear that has
existed in computer science going back
to at least 1960. so norbert weiner the
mit cyberneticist was writing about this
um and you know he says if we
we use to achieve some purpose a
mechanical agency that we can't
interfere with once we've started it
uh then we had better be quite sure
that the purpose that we put into the
machine is the thing that we really want
um and i think a lot of people
increasingly since like 2014
it has become more and more mainstream
within the computer science community
itself as one of the most significant
challenges
facing uh the field as we sort of enter
this era of
ai that we may develop systems
which you know we with the best of
intentions try to encode some objective
into the system
the system with you know sort of the
best of intentions attempts to do
what it thinks we want um but there's
some fundamental misalignment
and that results in you know whatever
whatever the harm may be whether
it's um you know dark-skinned people not
getting
recognized by um you know facial
recognition system
or disparities in the way that parole is
being
um dealt with you know at a societal
level
um it could be self-driving cars that
failed to recognize jaywalkers and so
they kill anyone who's crossing in the
middle of the street because there were
no jaywalkers in their training data we
may actually throw society as a whole
off the rails um by some system with
you know enough power to shape the
course of human civilization but uh
without the appropriate wisdom to to
know exactly what to be doing
paper clips everybody everybody turns
into paper clips
exactly yeah so the paper clip maximizer
is kind of the classic thought
experiment
that goes back to uh nick bostrom and
eliezer yudkowski
and i think there's to my mind there's a
kind of a significant culture shift
that happens within the field of ai
around 2015
um and that is that you know in some
ways we no longer need the paper clip
maximizer thought experiment
because we have this like growing
file folder of actual real world
alignment problems gone wrong you know
whether it's social media you know we
optimized our news feed for engagement
and it turns out that
um you know radicalization and
polarization is highly engaging so you
know
we paper clipped ourselves in that
there's this quote uh that from norbert
weiner in your book which i
really thought encapsulated what we're
talking about nicely
in the past a partial and inadequate
view of human purpose has been
relatively innocuous
only because it has been accompanied by
technic technical limitations
human incompetence has shielded us from
the full destructive impact of human
folly
awesome just frames so much of what
we're talking about
so basically is it is the game a
balancing act between technological
capability and technological wisdom
largely speaking i would say yes um you
know and and
weiner used the phrase know-how versus
know what
um and increasingly we're seeing this
as a kind of a paradigm shift in the
field of computer science
the standard ai textbook that um is used
across the world is called artificial
intelligence and modern approach by
stuart russell and peter norvig
and they've just now released their
updated fourth edition
um and one of the things that we're
seeing
in that in the new edition is kind of
this
focus shifting from you have some
objective
what what is the swiss army knife of
tools in your toolkit to optimize that
objective
um we're now shifting to let's let's
take for granted that you can optimize
whatever objective you have
how do we figure out what is the right
objective to actually encapsulate all
the things that you
really want um and so
i mean part of what i think is very
significant is that
um we are starting to turn this question
of
no what into uh importing
all of these complicated human desires
human norms
into the language uh of optimization
um so that um that's that's the
optimistic side of the story that's the
hope
is that we can actually make a science
out of the sort of the know what part
yeah i mean surely we don't want we
don't know what we want as humans
right now anyway i mean the fields of
ethics and morality
are still contested from human to human
like how are we going to code
a poorly defined concept into a language
that machines can read
i'm unfortunately you know it's
happening uh
whether we're doing it well or not we
are doing it you know you see this
at facebook there is this process of
reading user behavior um and trying to
figure out from the click on the stuff
people engage with
what it is they appear to want and i
think people
underestimate the sophistication of
these systems like we have these
intuitions that
okay you know facebook or twitter or
whatever is tracking everything i click
on
oh that's that's the tip of the iceberg
um you know they're keeping track of how
many milliseconds is a particular ad
on screen so even if you're just
scrolling through and you hesitate ever
so slightly to read
a piece of text or look more closely and
then move on
they know that and you know as you say
we have a very impoverished sense of
how to map human behavior to human
desire or human value
and there's often this tension right you
know daniel kahneman tells us that we
have these
system one and system two and they're
often at odds with each other
um you know there's a reason that
supermarkets put the candy
right next to the register so that you
know you don't have time to second-guess
yourself
um and i think there's a genuine
challenge for social media companies
which is
how do you uh you know even if you're
acting with good faith even if all you
want to do is what users will want
how do you distill some notion of what
they want out of their behavior
um you know and one one example that i
give in the book um
someone i know uh has is an alcoholic
has an alcohol
addiction and social media companies
have
found out that if you show images of
alcohol
in an ad this person will linger
um and that creates this this horrible
feedback loop and so
um i think there really is this question
which is
um you know to borrow a phrase from nick
bostrom
this is philosophy on a deadline um
there are these open questions in not
just ethical philosophy but
cognitive science um neuroscience even
but we don't have time to in a way we
don't have time to wait for the answer
because
um these companies are just going
and so we're going to have to try to
essentially fix fix the plane
mid-flight so to speak yeah i mean
i read super intelligence which is kind
of i guess the seminal book
on this at least it was in the mid to
2015's uh and anyone anyone who really
wants to kind of get
a good overview i think that's a
fantastic place to go
stuart russell's human compatible as
well his new one is
awesome and then if you want if you want
to terrify yourself about everything
else as well as ai
uh toby odds the precipice like that
that's my perfect three book garage
for existential risk right there yeah
but
upon reading that that really kind of
opened my eyes to just
how big the potential dangers
are that we're playing around with here
and um
i i struggle to feel optimistic
and i don't know whether that is because
the scarier news stories make the
headlines
or because ai programmers tend to
uh now it would appear that from 2014 i
think you talk about
the difference in one year of going to a
conference someone brought up ai
security one year
and was kind of laughed out of the room
brought up ai security the next year and
nobody raised an eyebrow
so there really was a very rapid pivot
um that i think nick bostrom can
probably take a good amount of credit
for
um i agree and stuart yeah yes um
i wonder whether the ai researchers are
now
so cataclysmic so
um existentially aware that perhaps
they're
only showing us the the terrifying stuff
i don't know
yeah i mean i think it's worth making a
little bit of a distinction
between the actual ai safety research
community which is
a small subset of ai researchers
themselves
um and even people who self-identify as
ai people you know ai researchers
there's a much larger community of data
scientists
that do the more sort of day-to-day
machine learning work at actual
companies
um so it may be the case
that um you know the negative stories
are coming to the fore within the group
of people that's kind of committed to
working on these things
and that i think that's a good thing i
mean part of the story that i try to
tell
in this book is the uh you know the
birth of that community
um really the beginning i sort of think
of books like super intelligence
as um a kind of cosmic you know breaking
the glass and pulling the fire alarm
um and so you know the analogy that i
to sort of continue that analogy i think
about you know the beginning of this ai
safety research
movement as kind of like the first
responders have arrived at the scene
um and so i think there's kind of a
constructive story to be told about like
we're actually getting things done
um we're sort of meeting that challenge
um there is a question
of how does that fit into kind of the
broader culture of ai i think
um a lot of people are just
in some ways more heads down um
just trying to solve actual business
problems and so there's a question of
how do we
import some of the insights that we have
been learning in the safety community
into the more sort of user facing stuff
so i think that that's part of the part
of the process as well
have you got some good examples that can
explain to
the listeners how alignment works or how
it doesn't work um
yeah i guess those are two different
questions um
i mean how it doesn't work um there are
many ways right so there's this question
of
um you know you have a system you wanted
to do x
what could you know you you give it a
set of examples and you say you know
do that you know do this kind of thing
what could go wrong
um well there's this laundry list of
things could that could go wrong so one
thing
is um the examples that you gave it
um there's some kind of fundamental
mismatch with
the reality and so one of the things
that you hear about a lot
is kind of racial demographic mismatch
so
um you know there's a facial recognition
data set developed in the 2000s
that was built by scraping images from
newspapers online and so the composition
of faces in the data set
mirrors the types of people that
appeared
in kind of first world you know north
american
you know european newspapers um
in the 2000s so the most prevalent
person in this data set is george w bush
who was the u.s president during that
time
and so it turns out for example there
are twice as many pictures of george w
bush as there are of all black women
combined um but in the real world there
are not twice as many george w bush's as
all black women combined and so you have
this fundamental mismatch between
the set of examples that you've used and
the actual
kind of reality and so this is something
that um
the technical name for this would be
robustness to distributional shift
so um is your
system capable of handling the fact that
the examples that it encounters out in
the real world are coming from some
different
distribution than what it learned on you
know when you were training it
so that's a fundamental question is just
um
what is the kind of data provenance like
what what examples went in
and does that match the environment that
you're going to deploy it in
and there are many many examples of this
um you know i think the racial bias
stuff has obviously made headlines
but there are subtler examples for
example um there was a google system
that uh upon inspection was you
it turned out that the color red was
intrinsic to its classification of
something as a fire truck
um and most fire trucks in the u.s are
red
in the uk i think they're also red um in
australia they're
white and neon yellow um and so
you know that model would not be safe to
deploy in your self-driving car
if you were in canberra or something um
so that's
i think a very fundamental you know
category of thing it's just are the
examples that you've given
do they match the sorts of things it's
going to see in the real world
and the second large category is
what's called the objective function so
every machine learning system has some
numerical specification of what it is
that you want the system to do
um and often things can go very
subtly but importantly wrong in how
you've specified what you want the
system to do
so one example of this um
one of my favorite examples comes from
this robotic soccer competition
um that was being held in the 1990s and
this team from stanford including astro
teller who's now the head of google x
they decided they would give their
robotic soccer
uh team this little tiny incentive
for taking possession of the ball um so
the the overall goal was like to score
points and win the game
but as kind of a incremental incentive
they
they were awarded you know the
equivalent of like a hundredth of a goal
for taking possession of the ball
because they thought that would
incentivize the right sort of
strategy you can't score until you have
the ball etcetera
but what their robots learned to do was
to just
approach the ball and then vibrate their
paddle as quickly as possible
um taking possession of the soccer ball
uh you know 100 times a second and this
was much easier than actually scoring
points
um so there are many i mean this is just
one example but
it turns out that you know actually
trying to
specify numerically exactly what you
want
this program to do is extremely
difficult to the point
that it's kind of increasingly
considered um
just unsafe to ever attempt to do that
so we and then we can get into what it
what it looks like to
not specify it but yeah so
the overarching theme that i felt on
going through your book is it feels to
me like do you remember
that advert of the guy using its real
hard
core strength gaffer tape to stop a
flood coming out
the side of a water tank it was like
from the 90s
he's got like a big bit of black tape
and this there's this hole in the side
of a water tank and he's like look how
strong this
wax of tape on it it feels to me
like a lot of the incentive
coding structure is that guy
sticking waterproof tape on all the
little holes
surely it's not going to be scalable to
try and predict
every different permutation of what's
potentially going to go wrong
increasingly i think the field is coming
to
exactly the view that you're they should
have just they should have just come
and had a chat with the guy with the
with the tape
on the on the thing and he would have
told them
that's right yeah well on you know we're
maybe a couple decades late to that
to the party but um we're coming around
um so yeah there has been uh i would say
something of a revolution
within um computer science and i think
stuart russell
gets a lot of credit for this um he
developed this um
technique in around the turn of the
millennium
called inverse reinforcement learning so
reinforcement learning is what i was
talking about with soccer where you have
some kind of goal which is known as the
reward function
um that kind of doles out points to your
system and then it's the system's job to
optimize its behavior to get as many
points as it possibly can
that's reinforcement learning so inverse
reinforcement learning
goes the other direction it says we're
going to observe
some expert behaving so we're going to
watch a soccer player or we're going to
watch
someone uh you know play chess
or whatever it might be and figure out
what the score of the game must be
if this person's an expert player then
we're going to try to work backwards
from their behavior
to the rules of the game and what the
point system is
and the basic idea here is that
it offers us perhaps
you know hopefully fingers crossed
this paradigm offers us something that's
going to be more robust as we
develop systems with kind of flexible
capabilities in real world environments
that they can just kind of observe human
behavior
and try to work backwards from that to
an actual numerical specification of
um of what we care about essentially
rather than us having to somehow write
it all down on paper ourselves
there's a number of hurdles that we need
to overcome you need to
first off write down what we want we
also need to then translate that into
code that can be understood by the
machines
but first we actually need to know what
we want and a lot of the time what we
think we want
might not actually be correct we might
not understand the externalities of
asking for the thing that we want
even if the machine achieves it
perfectly and there's no
machine side malignant side effects or
externalities that it's done
we could just specify the wrong goal or
we might not understand what that goal
will be so yeah it certainly seems like
trying to bypass our idiocy by using
the outcomes that we end up at is a
fairly clever way to go about it
what what does fairness have to do with
the alignment problem
i thought this was quite interesting it
was something i hadn't come up against
before
yeah um so there's
there have been historically a number of
ideas within computer science that have
been referred to as
fairness um you get for example fair
allocations in game theory you get fair
scheduling on a you know an operating
system when every
program gets a certain amount of time to
run but
starting in let's say 2010 the field of
computer science really became
preoccupied with a notion of fairness
that took into account
something closer to our kind of ethical
or
legal notion of fairness which is to say
like
are different groups of people affected
uh differently by a machine learning
system
so the canonical example of this
is pre-trial detention so in the u.s
if you're arrested uh you have this
arraignment hearing before a judge
and they set the date of your trial the
trial could be
months away weeks away months away and
then there is this very specific
decision that gets made which is are you
going to be
held in jail before your trial
or are you going to be released to go
home before your trial
um and this is where bail cash bail ends
up getting
uh involved in certain states um
increasingly throughout in the last
couple decades
but really accelerating in the last five
years or so
um states have been using
these algorithmic risk assessments that
just give a score like
one to ten how risky is this person if
we release them
back you know into society pending their
trial
um these have been used by many
jurisdictions there are states passing
laws mandating the use of these sorts of
things
and so there's been a lot of scrutiny on
are these models fair and there's you
know in the u.s
we have civil rights legislation going
back to the 60s and 70s that articulate
certain legal definitions of fairness
but they're not
necessarily obvious how those actually
apply to like a statistical
uh instrument um and so and a bit of a
controversy around this particular tool
called compass which is just one of many
of these
kind of pre-trial risk assessment tools
um so
it turns out that compass is what's
called
calibrated which means that if you're
given an 8 out of 10 risk score then
you have the same probability it turns
out to be rearrested whether you're
white or black
and this is kind of the canonical
definition of quote-unquote fairness
that's been used for many decades
but increasingly people are looking at
these alternative definitions of things
like
okay well if you look at the people for
whom the model makes an
error does it make the same kinds of
errors or
are they different in some way and you
see for example that
the black defendants who are um
miscategorized by the model
are two to one relative to white
defendants to be judged riskier than
they really are
whereas white defendants conversely are
uh the ones that are miscategorized are
two to one
more likely to be uh judged as less
risky than they really
are and so people are saying okay well
this this feels like
sort of a disparate impact that we would
ideally like to mitigate
as well if we want the system to be fair
um
along come the computer scientists and
say
well it turns out actually that it's
mathematically impossible to satisfy
both of those definitions of fairness at
the same time
and so this is uh one of these cases
where
human intuitions
kind of run into these uh technical
challenges and we need essentially a
a kind of public policy conversation
around okay well when these
things that we you know seem equally
desirable
um can't be mutually satisfied you know
who decides
what the priority should be so this ends
up being a very complicated uh
kind of policy slash legal slash
computational question as you can
imagine it gets pretty
intricate why were the black defendants
did the computer scientists were they
able to look at what was occurring that
meant that the
black defendants were being judged to be
more
likely or higher in terms of the error
rate
yeah i mean there's a there's a couple
um components
so for one the model
actually makes three different
predictions that sometimes get conflated
one of the predictions is the person's
risk
of failing to appear for their trial
date
one is their risk of non-violent offense
and the other is the risk of violent
offense
and one of the important things to note
is that
these are three fairly different
predictions in terms of our ability to
actually observe the thing that we
are trying to measure so if you don't
appear
in court uh the government basically
by definition knows that you didn't
appear in court so it's essentially a
perfectly observable
um event if you um
now the the model is attempting to
predict whether you will commit a crime
but we don't
know whether someone commits a crime we
only know whether the person is arrested
and convicted um which may or may not
mean that they committed a crime and
uh it's interesting because for the
research of this book
i ended up digging into the now almost
100 year long history of these sorts of
models that goes back to
chicago in the 1920s was the first one
um
and to my surprise in the 30s it was
conservatives making this argument of
like now wait a minute some guy goes on
a crime spree but
he doesn't get caught and as far as the
model is concerned he's you know a
perfect citizen
that doesn't seem right because now the
model is going to recommend that we
release more people like that
these days you're more likely to see the
critique coming from progressives that
say
now wait a minute someone's gotten
wrongfully arrested and wrongfully
convicted
now the model thinks they're a criminal
and it's going to recommend detaining
more people like that
um and so it's funny you know
historically the kind of prevailing
political valence of the critique has
flipped but it's the same underlying
critique which is that
we can't actually measure the thing that
we're attempting to predict which is
crime
um and so if there are kind of
you know striking disparities in the way
that we actually observe
crime then that is going to
um essentially filter downstream into
the model
so for example in manhattan um
the last statistics that i heard was
something like
black and white manhattanites
self-report
marijuana use at about the same level
but black manhattanites are 15 times
more likely
to be arrested for marijuana possession
and so here there's a huge gap between
what we can ostensibly
predict and what we can actually measure
um
and so this has led i mean there's
there's a lot to
unpack in this area but this has led
people for example
to make the argument that you should
essentially
trust the failure to reappear
uh prediction but not trust the
non-violent offense
prediction because the one we can
observe much more accurately than the
other
um so that's a little bit of a flavor of
how some of these
um imbalances and how crime is actually
like observed by the police
then filters down into the model's
assessment of someone's quote unquote
risk
can we talk about neural networks what
some of the
problems are that you find with neural
networks and why it's so hard to get an
explanation out of a black box
yeah um so part of the reason that you
know you and i are having this
conversation
now and that you know we've seen books
like nyx and stewart's and
toby's um in the last
you know eight years or so um is because
of the rise of deep neural networks
which really kicked off in 2012.
um and so i mean it's ironic because
the neural network is one of the oldest
ideas that anyone had in computing it
predates the stored program computer
um which i think is kind of amazing um
so it is about as old an idea as
anyone's ever had in computer science
and ai
but it was not until 2012 that it
actually started to work
um so there's a very fascinating uh
history there
but basically um neural networks have
come to dominate
uh all of the previous approaches that
people were using in the 2000s
and have just kind of swept through
computer vision computational
linguistics
speech to text processing machine
translation
reinforcement learning you name it there
has been kind of just this successive
series of um kind of discontinuous
breakthroughs as a result of neural
networks
um they are famous they have a
reputation for being kind of inscrutable
um and uninterpretable and so a big
frontier in ai safety research is
finding ways to essentially pop the hood
so to speak
and figure out what in the heck is going
on inside of a neural network
um and i think that's a that's maybe one
of the more encouraging stories
in ai alignment research because we're
making more
headway than honestly i expected
what's the problem why can't you you've
got you've got a thing you've got this
neural network
it it does a thing why can't it tell you
why it did it well
um it's sort of like a problem of
information overload so
let me use as an example the kind of
flagship
first real success story in deep
learning
which is this image recognition system
called alexnet
that was uh used in so
alex net was designed to take in
uh an image and i'm trying to remember
what the dimensions of the image were it
could have been like 100 pixels by 100
pixels or something like this
um and
ultimately somehow output one out of a
thousand different categorizations is
this a truck is this a kitten is this a
you know sandy beach what is this
um and so you know at
at the simplest level you just have
pixels in
and categorization out and so what's
going on in the middle
well uh 100 by 100 pixels is 10
000 pixels and it's rgb so you have
a total of 30 000 inputs that represent
this picture
um and they're just encoded as numbers
from like 1 to 255 or from zero to 255
for how
how much red is in location x
how much blue is in location y um
and this goes into a network of
about 600 000 of these
artificial neurons and the artificial
neuron is
extremely simple it just takes in these
little inputs
and it adds them up and it says
is the sum of these inputs above a
certain threshold
and if it does then it will sort of pass
along
some number as an output to the next
neurons in the chain
so it's very interpretable in the sense
that you can look at an individual
neuron
and say like okay what were its inputs
okay it's getting a 10 here a 5 there
it's adding them up
it's greater than something so it's then
outputting a whatever
um but it's very and so you multiply
that by
600 000 neurons in you know 12 layers or
whatever and there's a total of like
60 million connections between all the
different ones
and at the end you get a number between
you know one and a thousand that tells
you
truck you know barbecue grill whatever
um the question is
it's not a it's not a problem you you
know exactly
what happened so to speak in that it's
just adding numbers and comparing them
to thresholds
um but what in the hell does neuron you
know the neuron in layer five
you know getting a an eight at one
25 adding that up and then outputting a
two
like what does that mean
um and so that's really the question is
it's a system that's kind of perfectly
describable
in detail but um it's like being given
you know an atomic description of what's
going on in someone's brain
um when they laugh and then trying to
figure out like well what makes
something funny
well let's look at this you know
hydrogen atom over here
um that's it's just sort of like the
wrong level of description
and so that that is kind of the
fundamental problem that we have with
neural networks
wasn't there an interesting implication
around gdpr
yeah so the european union had um
this draft version of the gdpr bill
um that was circulating around 2016 or
so
and it had this language in it which
kind of
raised the eyebrows of these two
researchers at oxford bryce goodman and
seth flaxman
and they said now wait a minute this
draft version of the bill appears to
create this legal concept that everyone
has a right to an explanation of
if you're affected by an algorithmic
decision if you're denied a mortgage or
you
don't get a credit card that you apply
for or whatever you are entitled to
to know why um and yet
it was widely understood that you
couldn't obtain some an answer like that
from a deep neural network and so this
created something of a
i don't know a panic between the legal
departments of tech companies and the
engineering departments
um and i remember hearing a lawyer for
one of the big tech companies
i won't say which one talking about
meeting with eu regulators and saying
now you realize that you're putting into
law something which is like
scientifically impossible um
and the regulators were sort of unmoved
and they said well that's why you have
you know doesn't go into effect for two
years so you know figure it out
um and i think this is a very you know
we think of regulation as almost by
definition stifling innovation but here
is a case where
the regulators demanded something that
the scientists then
were given a two-year deadline of like
figure it out and so suddenly there was
this huge
um you know wave of money and
uh you know research attention going
into this problem but it's still
i mean it's there are a lot of really i
think promising techniques
but in terms of this question of what is
the explanation for why something
happened in a neural network
it's still it's not even clear what is
legally
sufficient to please the eu let alone
what is kind of
standard practice at this point so it's
still a bit of an unresolved question
even now
i was listening to one of the engineers
behind the youtube algorithm talking
and then lex friedman must have seen the
same video clip that i did and he
brought it up
on a show and he was talking about just
how terrifyingly little
youtube knows about their own algorithm
now
that this thing is just a runaway
fisherian reinforcement monster
that is optimizing and doing things
but to be honest they kind of don't
really know
what's going on like can you just speak
to that how can it be
that programmers that make a thing
after it's been left to run for a little
while no longer know what it's doing
essentially
yeah and you know i i've heard this from
people high up in the engineering works
um of these companies saying yeah we
have no idea what it's doing but
it's making so much money that we can't
turn it off um
you know this is how this is how horror
movies begin right
um so i mean in some ways that's the
that's the point of neural networks was
precisely that they could do the things
that we couldn't articulate in code
right like writing if you think about it
as a
contrast to writing sort of traditional
software where you
sit down and you type you know if x then
go to
line 12 or you know whatever that sort
of canonical
style of programming there's a whole set
of things that that couldn't do
namely the things that we didn't know
how to explain
our own thought process so it's really
good for sort of mimicking your
explicit deliberate thought process but
it's really hard for doing
um kind of sense perception or motor
skills or things like that that don't
have like an explicit reasoning you can
step through
but the dark side of that is that
um you don't understand how the computer
is doing it either
um and so yeah there's been a lot of
um i don't know certainly
i hear a lot of hand wringing from
people at tech companies that say like
okay we just pipe in you know all the
possible data that we have about this
person their browsing history their
credit cards
their um everything they've ever clicked
on ever you know whatever it might be
into this thing and it just spits out
you know show them this thing
and not that thing and like when we
don't really know
how that you know is being arrived at
but
we know that when we do it we make more
money than when we don't do it
um and so there's this weird kind of
like well let's just let it
let it rip um so
that i mean that's exactly the kind of
thing that people who are worried about
ai safety are worried about
right well the problem here
and the best podcast i think i've heard
on this
was rob reed from after on
he had naval ravicant on and they were
talking about
um privatized gains versus socialized
losses
yeah and that paradigm so essentially
that if you are a private company who
has one of these ridiculous algos that
is able to just
it's a money machine and you run it and
it's able to
show the perfect advert to the perfect
person at the perfect time or it can
create
the best sandwich or it makes the
amazing computer game or does whatever
but risks potentially turning the entire
world into paper clips
you are privatizing all of the potential
gains
but the entire world is risking all of
the losses
it's what you get when you have a shared
commons as well it's why people
in some developing countries are
slightly less concerned about polluting
the atmosphere because they only pollute
a bit of the atmosphere but they get all
of the profit
um and when you hear about these things
man like
you know youtube i don't think that
susan was jijicki
is trying to cause the downfall of
human civilization but i do think that
she probably wants to maximize watch
time
and sadly these two things as the power
continues to increase within the
algorithms and the computing
space these two things are going to
start to converge more and more
yes and i think um
in some ways i think the alignment
problem is
bigger than a.i um that it is really a
description of what's going wrong
in capitalism in global governance
that there are a number of situations
and
and again this is not just an ai thing
where
someone defines some metric that
sort of kind of encapsulates what we
want um
at the end of the day youtube or netflix
or whatever doesn't
really care about how much you watch
they just care about how much money they
can make and
you know can they minimize churn and
maximize user retention blah blah blah
um and someone says well watch time
seems to be mostly correlated with all
that stuff and it's a lot easier to
you know uh operationalize so let's just
for the sake of argument
maximize watch time or you know at
tinder
there was this long period of time i as
far as i know years
where the metric that their engineers
were asked to optimize was swipes per
week
um and
this is basically the alignment problem
like full stop
we come up with some reward function
that
kind of sort of contains what we're
trying to do but not
entirely and then we optimize the
dickens out of that
specification beyond the point at which
it uh correlates with the thing we
really care about
um and so you know this goes back to
where we started our conversation
premature optimization is the root of
all evil
at what point you know how how long did
it take for someone at tinder to say
now are swipes per week really what
we're about like is that
really the the um
top of the pyramid of you know metrics
that we're trying to achieve here
um same thing with watch time right like
for me i don't know if it's the case
anymore for a long time netflix was
explicitly maximizing watch time
and there was some quote if i'm calling
this correctly where they said like
we're competing against you know playing
sports we're competing against reading a
book we're competing against like
talking to your kids um and yeah
it just sounded like horrible
um but how long does it take before
someone
starts to realize like oh maybe maybe
that's not the match
the metric you know that we're like
going for and i think the same thing is
happening in society at the highest
level right we've been
maximizing gdp per capita quarterly
returns
um you name it uh
while creating these socialized
externalities called climate change
called the increasing genie coefficient
etc etc
and so um
now the question is whether to be sort
of extra pessimistic or extra optimistic
by thinking about this as not really an
ai problem per se
right because um i'm maybe more
confident that we can solve this
at a technical level than i am that we
can sort of change global governance
or reform capitalism in some like very
macro
way um on the other hand
there is maybe a glimmer of hope that
some of these techniques that people are
developing
in the ai context things like inverse
reinforcement learning um
might actually be useful uh to
tech companies for a start and even
something like
um you know a national government
where they say instead of
manually designing some objective
function about what we're
trying to do um we'll do the inverse
reinforcement learning thing where we
will just
um present real people with kind of
different scenarios and ask them to pick
like which of these
you know which of these newspaper front
pages you know
from the year 2030 seems to portray a
better world
um and then we'll somehow try to back
the metrics
out of that rather than having to
come up with the metrics ourselves um so
tech companies are starting to do these
sorts of things
um and it will i know to me that's the
glimmer of hope is maybe we can get
ourselves to a sort of
uh unwind the tyranny of these
kpis that are sort of like controlling
everything about society at the
highest level you get to something a
little bit more holistic yeah
it really does seem like you pick a
metric
as a engineer as a company that you
think is the closest approximation to
what you deem success
for the particular out of the particular
company that you're running
there is a reward function that's given
to the algorithm for meeting that
particular criteria
but that criteria might not achieve
the best way to get that outcome so
let's say that it's time on site
there's nobody that i don't know that
wishes this they didn't spend less time
on the phone
there's nobody that i know that looks at
instagram for two hours and
retrospectively says that was a good use
of my time
but you could imagine in another world
that instagram actually provided an
experience
which kept people on site for two hours
and retrospectively they were happy
that they'd been on for two hours now
currently they're not
yeah and i don't know if instagram could
ever achieve that with the particular
platform but we can imagine some other
sort of app that could
if it was able to optimize itself in a
way
where it was actually achieving the
outcome
that made people want to use the app
rather than just race to the bottom of
the brainstem and manipulated them in
ways
that almost forced them to use the app
you would still get the same outcome
that you wanted
which was particularly screen time but
all
of the root causes of how you arrive at
the screen time have been changed
and we would probably mostly be able to
agree that that's
uh at the advance of the well-being of
the user who is doing it
yeah yeah so i mean there's always been
this tension between
the copious data that's easy to collect
you know we can measure every click we
can now measure the
milliseconds of every item on the screen
being on screen
and then there's this data that's really
hard to collect which is you know these
qualitative judgments of
asking people like how happy are you how
satisfied are you
um maybe you go to someone a week later
or a year later
and so you can't directly directly
optimize for these things in tight
feedback loops because it's too hard to
get the feedback or you have to wait a
year to get the feedback
and so it can't be part of your actual
kind of day-to-day
um iterative loop but what you can do
is try to use something like inverse
reinforcement learning or there you know
some more sorts of causal models to
figure out
how the data that you can observe
might predict these sorts of scarce
expensive
long-term things that you really want
and rather than
just directly optimizing the feedback
that you have on hand
do the more indirect thing of like we
need to model
how the stuff we can observe affects
these things downstream
and try to optimize for those things
downstream by way of these proxies
um i think that is starting to happen
um and
it's not quite as simple as just waving
the magic
wand but i think that's exactly the kind
of approach that we need
is this going to be able to be achieved
without some sort of systemic change in
terms of governance in terms of policy
in terms of the way that we step into
the algorithms the power of the
algorithms the amount of computing power
the amount of transparency that people
can
these companies can see into their black
boxes or maybe even the way that they
generate their revenue
um because right now
from where i'm sitting it seems like
tech companies are able to make more
money than
ever before using increasingly advanced
uh neural networks and algorithms
but that is being done at the expense
of a lot of other things that we
probably don't want to depreciate
anymore it feels to me
as if we are at a little bit of a a
precipice
toby or perhaps like the the apex of a
of a curve where you if we were to push
much further
i think that you would start losing we
may have already gone past it but i
think that we actually start to lose
so much of civilization that the
advantages that we begin to get
from technology are
negative utility i agree with you and i
think
that may be true even if you are
in the in a completely self-interested
position at a tech company
you know for example google and facebook
have now
relative to 10 years ago lost so much of
the public's goodwill
that you know when the department of
justice
swings the anti-trust hammer um you know
are
are people gonna cheer or are they gonna
protest right and that makes a
difference like so good will
um may seem like this kind of gossamer
you know ineffable thing but it
manifests
yeah you know it may shatter your entire
corporation how do we fix it
i mean i i do think at some level there
is this
kind of room for these more technical
solutions um
and so you know my feet are planted more
squarely in the research community and
so
you know i can see the development of
some of these things
and how you know for example at berkeley
where i'm affiliated
a lot of the phd students in technical
ai safety
have started doing summer internships at
tech companies
and i think that's very interesting it's
sort of a
a marker of the kind of maturity of
technical ai safety in just a few years
that
some of the stuff that was on white
boards in 2017
2018 is now getting actually mocked up
as this kind of mvp thing
at an actual tech company so
that seems good um i think
one of the major forces that holds a lot
of tech companies in check
is the fact of how much power the actual
employees themselves have
currently machine learning is in such
high demand
that good machine learning engineers
have a ton of leverage
and they're able to use that leverage
to kind of convince companies to do
certain benevolent things like publish
publish results openly you know in
public journals or publish
things directly onto the web or release
open source
things that companies wouldn't
necessarily be otherwise disposed to do
has now become sort of part of the norm
of the field and that's
not coming from competitive pressure
necessarily it's not coming from
regulators it's coming from
just the consciences of the individual
engineers and the fact that they have
leverage uh over their employers because
they're in this like
extremely high demand category
now it may not always be the case
because as the ranks of machine learning
engineers grow
because this field is so in demand then
the individual bargaining power of those
employees is going to
go down um so we're going to lose a
little bit of that leverage
does some of it come from regulators i
assume so but it is not clear to me what
shape that regulation is actually going
to take
um i mean i think um
some kind of
citizen participation you know like
i wouldn't mind something you know i say
in the book i think that
it it's reasonable to imagine that we
have some rights to know
what the model is that these companies
have of us
um and to have some kind of direct
influence over that
right so you're starting to see this a
little bit with alcohol which was the
example i mentioned earlier
where some tech companies now actually
have like a toggle somewhere deep into
the preferences that says like
never show me alcohol um that's like
the tip of the iceberg but you can
imagine a way in which
um you know you can have some control
over which version of yourself
is being marketed to right you can say
like yes
it turns out that i you know
when i'm in the checkout aisle i put a
bunch of candy on my thing
but i i want to not be that person so
please give me the checkout aisle that
has
you know free organizations whatever
fruit and vegetables
um and i you know in in theory that
should be a win-win
um but we'll see um
you know in in practice it's not totally
clear
um that they can present
makes sense to you or in a way that's
like directly manipulable
yeah so there are questions the main
thing
and i think that this kind of cuts to
the heart
of the discussion around the alignment
problem right now is that
the general tenor and tone
and feeling of users towards tech
companies
and of us towards ourselves and of our
relationship with technology
probably in the space of the last six
years to seven years has changed very
much
from technology being a tool that we use
to technology being a tool that uses us
and i think yeah it just feels to me
like
that's the
like we made these tools in an effort to
make
life more entertaining and rich and
all of these a man i've had hours tens
of hours
of conversations on this show through
this microphone
talking about we're more connected than
ever but i've never felt more alone what
does it mean for
young children to be spending time
looking at screens
like one of the one of the [ __ ] iron
prescriptions that i come up with is
that you need to spend more time looking
at the night sky
like in in what world should i be
prescribing the night sky
as like an antidote to the way that you
exist
and yet i am so
i think i yeah no i can't resist
mentioning that the night sky itself is
this externality of you know starlink
um that i mean to say nothing of urban
light pollution etc but
um you know part of the business model
of uh
starlink is to put a ton of satellites
into space that may or may not
mess up our view of the night sky but
it's not starling's problem
um and so yeah that's yet another
example of this kind of socialized
externality
so yeah i couldn't resist pointing that
out there's a
uh a girl who i had on the show uh mara
cortona
mara cortana who is the director of the
astropolitics politics institute
so this is this is the politics of space
[ __ ] man if that's not an interesting
like read it is
so cool like who owns space can we throw
our waste into space
can we like claim bits of space what
who owns the moon who owns mars it's so
this stuff's so fascinating but um yeah
man
as a sort of parting note what do you
think
that we can expect as normal users of
technology
what do you think that we can expect
from our sort of experience and our
interaction with technology over the
next
decade i think we're starting
to have a sense um
that we are interacting with technology
in a way in which all of our
all of our actions can and will be used
against us right it's like
you need to be mirandized to go online
or something
um that i i mean i i
don't know if you have this experience
as well but when i'm using let's say
youtube
um there's a part of me that
tries to decide before i look up a video
if i want to look it up in an incognito
tab
so that i kind of like you know
separate off cordon off like this is not
part of the preference model i want you
to build
of me even though i know they're going
to track my ip address and whatever but
it's not directly linked to the same
um you know viewing habits that i've
kind of laid down in the my regular
account with all the cookies in it um
i think there is going to be this
increasingly weird game theoretic aspect
to using technology where
we are constantly having to suss out
like what what inference is it going to
make
based on my behavior what is their
business model
um what kind of feedback loop will my
behavior
create um you know you hear these funny
stories of people saying like you know i
let my
two-year-old you know mess with my
spotify for a day and then my
recommendations have been ruined forever
you know things like that
um and i certainly have that experience
um that i feel that i'm dealing with
this kind of inscrutable
um you know intelligence or machinery or
whatever you want to think about it
um there's some process happening
of which i'm a part and it's
i'm being observed i'm being sort of
adapted to
the things that i see have some weird
relationship to what i've
interacted with before but i have no
idea what that relationship
is um and
i mean i think about twitter as one
example you know the twitter app
a lot of the stuff in my feed isn't even
from the people i follow it's this kind
of secondary and tertiary thing of like
someone that you follow like to tweet by
someone else who knows this other person
and this is their tweet and so as a
consumer you have no idea
like why why am i seeing this thing when
you go to make a tweet
you have no idea what process may or may
not determine
how that tweet reaches people or which
people it reaches
but we're sort of forced to play this
game
and we're forced to sort of co-adapt
with these models and i think that's
um that's one of the things that people
in technology
i think underestimate is that
if somewhere secretly in the you know
the bowels of twitter they start to add
a five percent
bump for posts that use like
highly emotional language or something
like that or just
that that naturally shakes out of the
optimization
um people will notice and people will
change their behavior accordingly
and so um you know the the technical way
of putting this is that you know machine
learning is secretly mechanism design
it's like
you you can't make a model without that
model becoming
uh so essentially an incentive structure
that people then
start to game and then the correlations
you previously observed
break down and so you constantly have to
kind of reevaluate it
um what do i think we can expect in the
next five to ten years
i think that
process of i don't know that that
i think that disempowering feeling of
just like
i have no idea what's going on here i'm
just kind of
experiencing it um i have this sense
that i'm part of this causal feedback
mechanism
and i don't really know exactly what
that how that works
but i need to take i know that i need to
take it into account
um because everything i engage with will
shape the future data that i even get
um i mean i think we were
we're going to see um
i think these subtle questions of like
what the actual business models of these
companies
are like really start to rear their head
in the
um the machine learning aspect i think
that's kind of underappreciated so for
example
um we have all these different apps that
recommend us things netflix recommends
us things amazon recommends us things
spotify recommends us things
um but
the business model in each case is quite
different and so that ends up actually
manifesting in very different
recommendations so amazon is this
logistics
behemoth and so they really benefit from
people
uh doing mainstream things if you buy
the book that's the number one book then
they probably have a copy of it just
like a few miles from your house and
it's going to be easier for them than if
you get an obscure book
um netflix is constantly renegotiating
the licensing rights with all these
film studios and tv studios so netflix
would prefer
if you watch the really obscure thing to
the really mainstream thing because they
can get the rights a lot cheaper
so amazon is giving you this kind of uh
centripetal force towards these sort of
main mainstream
modal things in the culture netflix is
the centrifugal force that's driving you
to these like obscure niches
um spotify has this kind of double-sided
marketplace thing where
if they put too many of the mainstream
artists in your recommended playlist
then the
indie record labels get mad and pull out
and so they're constantly wrangling
um to please both the listeners and the
musicians so all of these things end up
manifesting in the actual
behavior of the system but in ways that
are
um you know sort of tactically obscure
but strategically
clear um
i don't know where that leaves us
necessarily i think
it's going to be increasingly clear that
i don't know we need to figure out how
to give people a seat at the table
um that if there are things like
the health of public discourse at stake
um
we increasingly have the actual computer
science
to attempt to operationalize these
weirdly fuzzy things um you know i'm
thinking about
open ai gbt3 there are a lot of research
papers coming out
about you know these very ill-defined
concepts
that we have like for language um you
can actually sort of fine-tune gpt3 to
to meet these different criteria um so
the scientific piece is getting worked
out and the question that remains is
really like
how do we decide who gets a seat at the
table and whose opinion is it
and who's whose values are the values
that are getting imprinted into this
system
so that is i think the big question that
awaits us
even when we can solve the uh the
technical and scientific aspect of the
alignment problem
i think it comes back to what we said at
the very very beginning the balance
between technological capability and
technological wisdom
in that we are we are now
you're telling me that the very very
cutting edge of computer science
research and neural networks and gpt3
and all this stuff
is on the cusp of actually being able to
potentially open up
solutions to problems that most of us
have only just become aware of
so you're like you're so far ahead and
the iterations on this are
so rapid that
you know think about the lumbering
behemoth that is governmental policy
behind us and legislation um and and
psychological research into the effect
on humans long term
that is way way in the back that's in
the tail of snowpiercer
and then right on the very very front
getting battered by cold winds or a
couple of these computer science guys
and then the guy that's driving the
train is the person that's the algorithm
and then we're somewhere in the middle
find like
feeling it and we're like oh isn't it
interesting that all this stuff's going
on
so man yeah i mean the next the next 10
years is going to be is going to be
super super interesting
um i i have this
yeah i have this get out of jail free
card that
i've been using for absolutely ages
which is that
all of the problems that we're coming up
with now are not going to matter in a
hundred years
because we're either going to be
enslaved by a misaligned super
intelligent artificial general
intelligence
or will have managed to get a machine
extrapolated volition to work correctly
to the point where it fixes all of the
problems for us
so all of the stuff between now and then
is like some weird
reverse deterministic uh apathy fest
where we don't actually really need to
do anything it's like look
the end of the road's coming uh it could
be good could be bad
let's enjoy the ride on the way there
and i wonder i wonder how much the
contributions
of these smaller consequence
alignment problems are going to
contribute to us getting the big one
right
yeah um i mean i agree with your snow
piercer analogy broadly speaking
um and i don't know it's in some ways
it's even worse than that because uh
there's a computer scientist at
princeton named arvind orion who
has pointed out that a lot of the
systems that
are still integral to our financial
system and
you know airplane uh
controls are written in like pascal and
cobalt and these programming languages
that like barely anyone even knows
anymore
and so he was saying you know we have
this idea that tech moves too fast for
society to keep up
but in reality a lot of these like
crappy machine learning systems that
were developed in the 2010s are still
going to be around
like in zombie mode 20 years from now
and like maybe that's even more
terrifying
um so i think there is this question of
are we able to
catch these misalignment issues
in time to actually course correct
um some of them i feel more
sanguine about that than others um
maybe to push back a little bit on this
idea that we just need to relax
i mean there's this question so there's
kind of this philosophical question here
which is like
um you know this tension between moral
realism and moral relativism
um you know so if i've heard people
say that they are they identify as moral
realists so they think there are
objective truths about like right and
wrong
and that people are just bad at figuring
out
what those objective truths are and so
that's the kind of attitude that says um
you know i welcome our new
robotic overlords um the sooner they can
tell us
what's right and wrong the better um
that is kind of a
we can chill scenario i mean hope you
know assuming that um
that we get that hail mary pass right
and the system really is aligned but if
that's the case then
the moral realist uh you know overlord
just tells us what to do
um if you're kind of a moral relativist
then you have this idea that you know
whatever people
say is good is what's good um
i think there this idea of coherent
extrapolated volition which goes back to
eleazar yudkowski from machine
intelligence research institute
um has been uh very influential in the
ai safety community
um and it's this idea which
i think to some degree threads the
needle between those two things
which is to say you know the thing that
we want isn't just whatever people
happen to say when we pull them
it isn't some objective truth that we
could all be wrong about but it's this
idea of what what we would decide
if we were smarter if we had longer to
think about it if we could sort of
pull together in the appropriate way
i think in some ways that ends up
becoming the job
for the next hundred years um you know
philosophers like will mccaskill who's
toby's
colleague are saying you know we need
this period that they're calling the
long reflection
where we basically need to just
everybody just chill we need to take
maybe a million years
to just figure out what we want to do
with the cosmos and you know
take our time um there's this very
influential essay by nick bostrom called
astronomical waste um which says that
something like you know every second
that passes that we don't colonize the
stars is equivalent to like
um you know trillions of human lives
being lost that could have been lived
with that
you know uh uh
had we acted sooner and yet we still
need to take our time because the
consequence of screwing it up is
even worse um so there's a lot of
i don't know a lot of folks coming at ai
safety from the philosophy side saying
what we really need to do is just
chill like leave the space of
possibility
open um and
it's interesting to me because there's a
lot of technical ai safety work
on this idea of option value
preserving the ability of a system
to achieve various goals in the future
so
um you know something that you might
want in a system
is the system doesn't take actions which
permanently foreclose possibilities in
that
space whether it's shattering the vaws
that you can't put back together again
or killing the person that you can't
bring back to life whatever it might be
there are some really i think really
encouraging technical results
um in these sorts of toy environments
where if you give the agent
um randomly generated objective
functions
and say okay i want you to perform some
task
but preserve your option value to like
later do these randomly generated other
tasks
uh the system at least in these
simplified examples behaves with what
seems like a very human amount of
very delicate it won't just push the
ming voz
out of the way to you know run out the
door faster man that is
so interesting i hadn't heard about that
before but it make it makes
it makes complete sense that by forcing
it to retain
some level of optionality you
restrict the maximizing
ridiculous maximizing effect that it can
go after
man i uh i'm gonna once once we're
finished up i'm going to ask you for
some suggestions for
uh safety researchers and stuff because
i'm going to i'm going to force this
down the audience's throat over the next
year
yeah man brian uh i'll name check yeah i
will do
victoria covenant deep mind and um
uh one is one of the people working a
lot on this and uh there's an
idea by a guy named alex turner that's
called auxiliary utility preservation so
i'll send you some links and uh you can
you can share some of the actual papers
with that's my
bedtime reading finished uh man
thank you for coming on the alignment
problem how can machines learn human
values will be linked in the show notes
below
if people want to check out any more of
your stuff where should they go
um i'm on twitter at brian christian and
on the web at brianchristian.org
perfect man thank you so much for coming
on my pleasure thank you
[Music]